[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous faire une petite confidence
j'étais un peu inquiète de savoir
comment vous allez réagir en voyant ma
tenue de gendarme parce qu'en règle
générale quand les gens sont face à un
jardin vous avez deux réactions
possibles
vous avez ceux qui sont polis mais dont
la petite me trahit le dernier pv qu'ils
ont pris sur l'autoroute des vacances
si vous avez les autres dans leur
réaction est moins sympathique mais
relativement répandu ce qui nous insulte
qui nous caillasse ou qui avec leurs
voitures et 7 foncé sur ces de
pandore de schmidt ou de keufs et
lorsque vous êtes un gendarme féminin
vous avez parfois droit à une troisième
option et je vais vous raconter une
petite anecdote quand j'étais sur le
terrain en 2004 en tant que lieutenant
à l'époque on était peu d'officiers
féminin on était 1,5 pour cent des
officiers de gendarmerie en 7 7% à
l'heure actuelle je servais sur une
compagnie où venait de s'ouvrir le
centre national de rugby de marcoussis
et dans ce cadre là il y avait un
certain nombre de commissions de
sécurité qui était organisée par la
sous-préfecture donc quelques semaines
après l'ouverture du centre
une visite est d'organiser in situ alors
que l'équipe de france a pris ses
quartiers dans les bâtiments donc nous
cheminons faisons notre visite et un
moment nous traversons la salle de
musculation où s'entraînent une partie
des équipes de france et au moment où
nous passons j'entends une petite
remarque fusée et je comprend
immédiatement qu'elle m'est destinée à
je dirait pas non à une fouille à corps
lance un des joueurs à la cantonade
probablement pour faire rire ses petits
camarades
alors je vous ferai grâce de la remarque
qu'il a pris en retour mais tout ça pour
vous dire que et je vous donnerai pas le
nom mais tout ça pour vous dire que
lorsque vous êtes un gendarme féminin et
bien c'est parfois la double peine
parce que non seulement vous avez le
ressenti qu'expriment les gens contre
l'uniforme et l'autorité qu'il
représente mais en plus vous avez le
fait d'être essentiellement perçue comme
une femme une gendarmette dont on
aimerait bien qu'elle vous passe les
menottes dont on pose la question
pendant une perquisition mais pourquoi
vous êtes gendarmes une femme c'est fait
pour être à la maison
ou à qui on refuse de répondre parce que
on parle pas aux 9 et toutes ces
remarques sur le terrain je les ai
entendus et mes camarades féminines qui
sont en unités opérationnelles
les ententes régulièrement pourtant nous
sommes des gendarmes à part entière nous
sommes 17 % des militaires de la
gendarmerie qui assureront
quotidiennement la sécurité de la
population et apportons une diversité et
une vision complémentaire de la sécurité
il est très important que la diversité
de la société soient représentés dans
les forces de sécurité intérieure et que
les femmes puissent identifier certaines
de problématiques de sécurité sans leur
vécu leurs connaissances leurs
sensibilités certaines questions ne
serait pas posée et certaines
problématiques ne serait pas perçu
quand j'ai commencé au début des années
2000 on n'évoquait pas les
problématiques de sécurité sous le
prisme du genre d'ailleurs à l'époque
les statistiques ne faisait absolument
pas la distinction entre des hommes et
des femmes on comptait des faits des
moeurs des escroqueries des cambriolages
mais on ne discriminent est pas le genre
de la victime
et finalement on était face à une réelle
méconnaissance à la fois de la réalité
des violences exercées à l'encontre des
femmes notamment dans l'espace public
mais également de la différence de
perception entre les femmes et les
hommes
vous savez ce fameux sentiment
d'insécurité et puis quand on parlait
des problématiques qui touchent plus
spécifiquement les femmes
je pense aux violences conjugales aux
violences sexuelles on se focaliser
essentiellement sur la sphère privée
j'ai travaillé quatre ans à la
délégation victimes au ministère de
l'intérieur notamment sur la
problématique des violences faites aux
femmes au sein de cette structure
en 2006 nous avons été les premiers à
mettre en place l'étude sur les morts
violentes au sein du couple qui a révélé
pour la première fois en france qu'une
femme décède tous les trois jours sous
les coups de son compagnon ou
ex-compagnon
nous avons formé des policiers l'élan et
des gendarmes à la problématique des
violences faites aux femmes
nous avons accompagné des victimes dans
leurs démarches mais en quatre ans
jamais le sujet de l'espace public n'a
été abordé et pour deux raisons je pense
la première c'est que l'espace public a
toujours été perçu comme un espace de
liberté la liberté d'aller et venir
c'est un droit constitutionnel en france
et de ce fait cet espace est accessible
et ouvert à tous et donc là tout et puis
parce qu'en france il faut se souvenir
que lorsque vous êtes une femme vous
avez plus de risques d'être victime d'un
homicide ou de violences au sein de
votre couple ou de votre famille que sur
la voie publique alors enfin depuis un
ou deux ans la sécurité des femmes dans
l'espace public qu'il soit physique ou
numérique a fait son entrée dans le
débat public
on parle enfin de harcèlement de rue
d'inaccessibilité de certaines de
certains lieux aux femmes d' agressions
dans les transports de cyber sexisme
la plupart beaucoup en tout cas de
sondages et d'études ont démontré qu'au
cours de leur vie la plupart des femmes
avaient vécu des phénomènes tels que
être suivie dans la rue
être victime d'attouchements avoir subi
des propos sexistes ou insultant ou
avoir été victime d'un exhibitionniste
et finalement dans cette dans cette
démarche
la question est de savoir finalement si
face à cette réalité
face à ces situations est ce que on va
pouvoir agir
soit vous êtes confronté à des faits qui
sont clairement qualifiés pénalement et
dans ce cadre quand les victimes osent
déposé plainte
toute la difficulté dans l'espace public
sera pour les enquêteurs d'identifier
l'agresseur soit vous êtes face à des
comportements que moi je qualifie de la
drague lourde bresc de beaufitude dit
respect des femmes et la difficulté
c'est qu'à l'heure actuelle ces faits ne
sont pas qualifiés pénalement et que
s'il le devenait un jour du fait de la
loi
eh bien il restera la difficulté de la
constatation est pourtant des questions
se posent comment peut-on travailler sur
le sentiment d'insécurité des femmes
comment pouvoir évaluer cette insécurité
y at il une réelle insécurité des femmes
espace public où finalement et ont
confronté un ras-le bol qui s'exprime et
surtout comment agir sur tous ces
comportements inappropriés voire
délinquants pour permettre dans les
lieux publics aux femmes de bénéficier
d'une réelle égalité d'utilisation pour
préparer cette intervention je me suis
livré à un petit travail d'introspection
sur ce sentiment d'insécurité alors pas
en tant que gendarme parce que
finalement la sécurité est très
intériorisée comme faisant partie des
risques du métier mais plutôt en tant
que femme et je me suis posé la question
est ce que je me suis déjà senti en
insécurité dans l'espace public
oui il m'est revenu en particulier un
souvenir il ya quelques années dans une
station de métro déserte à 22h où je me
suis retrouvé suivi puis encadré par
deux individus que j'ai trouvé
particulièrement insistants est ce que
j'ai déjà été victime de harcèlement de
rue oui comme la quasi majorité d'entre
nous toutes et parfois même en présence
de mes enfants
et finalement je me suis posé la
question pourquoi je ressenti ce
sentiment
moi qui connais la dureté et la violence
de notre société
et bien parce que je me suis sentie
agressée verbalement esseulé et parce
que dans ce type de situation j'ai pensé
comme la plupart d'entre nous que si
quelque chose de grave
arrivé peu de gens interviendrait vous
savez cette fameuse dilution de
responsabilité ce phénomène d' influence
de groupes qui conduit un individu après
une phase de sidération à une perte de
sa responsabilité personnelle en raison
de la présence sociale d'autrui
cette posture qui fait que tout à chacun
se dit que après tout quelqu'un d'autre
interviendra et que si le voisin et
résines ne bouge pas pourquoi ils le
feraient et c'est une réalité dans les
cas les plus graves près de 88% des
témoins n'opposent aucune réaction
et je peux vous dire que les gendarmes
le constate tous les jours quand vous
posez la question à un témoin mais
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas appeler la
gendarmerie
que vous entendiez votre voisine sûrs
les victimes des violences de son
compagnon ou pourquoi n'êtes vous pas
intervenues pour porter assistance à
cette jeune fille qui se faisait
agresser la plupart des gens vous
répondront à non mais ça c'est pas mes
affaires
ou alors à mais il y avait d'autres
personnes pourquoi moi alors quelle est
la solution que les femmes apprennent à
se battre qu'elles évitent de sortir
vous avez beaucoup de femmes qui mettent
en place des stratégies d'évitement
quand elles sortent notamment le soir
vous avez des femmes qui ont pris le
parti de prendre des cours de self
défense
d'autres se sont munis d'armes type
bombe lacrymogène
si une démarche compréhensible mais
finalement est-ce que ça ne donne pas
toujours et encore cette idée que ce
problème est un problème de femmes et
uniquement de femmes
alors quelle est la solution ou une
partie de la réponse
en tant que citoyenne je vous dirais
très clairement que pour moi c'est avant
tout une question d'éducation notamment
des garçons et de respect des femmes
moi je suis maman de deux jeunes garçons
et je peux vous assurer que mon mari et
moi même sommes extrêmement vigilants
alors enseigner le respect de tous
femmes comme aux hommes mais en tant que
gendarme
ce qui me paraît essentiel c'est
l'engagement de chacun à la sécurité de
tous et je vais vous raconter ce qui
m'est arrivé il ya quelques mois dans le
métro parisien
je descends en plein après midi sur un
quai de métro très bon d et tout d'un
coup je l'entends une jeune femme hurler
mais vraiment ses hurlements
retentissent dans toute la station et je
ne vois pas la situation mais pour
autant je vois que personne ne réagit je
décide de remonter le quai pour
intervenir et je me rends compte qu'en
fait cette jeune femme n'est pas du tout
agressée elle fait une crise et son
compagnon essaie désespérément de la
calmer mais si ça avait été une
agression
pour ma part ça m'a semblé évitant
indispensable d'intervenir
pourquoi parce que je suis une femme
sorte de solidarité féminine peut-être
ou parce que j'ai été éduqué comme ça
suit la quatrième génération de
gendarmes et dans mon éducation comme
dans notre métier de gendarme la
protection de la population
l'obligation d'intervenir en service
mais également en dehors du service sous
peine d'être en état de prévarication
sont des choses qui sont inhérentes à
nos missions c'est dans notre adn
et je peux vous assurer que c'est
évident indispensable pour chaque
gendarme et c'est d'autant plus
indispensable dans l'espace physique
mais également dans l'espace numérique
et je pense que pour lutter contre la
délinquance
il faut justement que le civisme la
vigilance
le respect la bienveillance citoyenne
deviennent des réflexes pour nous tous
dans ses différents espaces parce que le
sujet est la réflexion se pose aussi
dans l'espace numérique
on en parle peu mais la gendarmerie est
très présente à la fois dans la lutte
contre la cyberdélinquance
mais également dans la prévention des
risques liés à l'internet en intervenant
notamment dans les établissements
scolaires pour sensibiliser les plus
jeunes et vous le savez il s'en passe
des choses sur internet
je vous parle même pas du darknet juste
l'internet grand public en 2015 une
étude des nations unies a démontré que
73% des femmes à travers le monde
avaient été victimes de violences par le
biais du net
que ce soit de l'intimidation du
harcèlement ou des menaces
il a encore une éducation à
l'utilisation sécurité de l'internet
mais également la vigilance et
l'engagement des internautes permettent
de signaler et de faire retirer un
certain nombre de contenus de photos de
vidéos de propos qui relèvent clairement
du cyber sexisme notamment par le biais
de d'une plateforme qui est hébergé au
ministère de l'intérieur
la sécurité et la sphère de tous en
entend beaucoup cette incantation
mais cela doit devenir beaucoup plus
qu'un slogan qu'une punchline ça doit
être une réalité dans notre pays et dans
un pays jacobin comme le nôtre
une petite révolution culturelle alors
oui il y a eu une prise de conscience
après les attentats de paris
une prise de conscience des citoyens
delà de l'obligation d'être vigilant
d'être sensibilisés aux actes à
accomplir en cas d'attaqué les choses
bougent lentement mais elle bouge mais
pour ce qui relève de la sécurité du
quotidien les réflexes sont beaucoup
plus personnel je pense qu'il faut dans
notre pays
éduquer la population il faut une réelle
éducation à la citoyenneté
il faut que la vigilance et l'engagement
de tous soit enseigné notamment aux plus
jeunes que le respect entre les femmes
et les hommes soient affirmées
comment réagir face à des violences des
incivilités
comment faire reculer le sentiment
d'insécurité notamment ressenti par les
femmes
comment vivre finalement dans une
société plus apaisé voilà ce qui doit
nous animer si nous voulons une société
plus sûre et de ce fait plus égalitaire
moi j'ai choisi la gendarmerie il y a
dix huit ans pour protéger la population
pour me mettre au service de la
collectivité de l'intérêt général comme
l'avait fait avant moi mon père mes deux
grands-pères et mon arrière grand père
et pour aussi démontré que les femmes
ont toute leur place dans les métiers
d'autorité et de responsabilité et kelly
sont légitimes
moi j'ai choisi le métier de la sécurité
est à l'égal des hommes
chaque jour j'assume ma mission avec
fierté et pour moi c'est ça aussi
l'égalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]